welcome back to cbs this morning it is
back to school season and our special
series school matters
is looking at the national picture
around schools and the coronavirus but
here's the thing about that national
picture
the policies vary at the state and local
level sometimes dramatically the u.s has
more than 13 thousand public school
districts
and i got to tell you almost as many
different plans for reopening
at least eight states are pushing back
their start dates or
going a step further and recommending
that some schools remain closed at least
for now
four other states ordered schools to
provide some form of
in-person instruction but for the vast
majority of the country the plans vary
not by
state but by district according to
education week which sampled hundreds of
communities all across the country
including the 100 largest school
districts in the u.s you can see them
right here
about a quarter of those districts are
planning partial or full
in-person reopenings but nearly
three-quarters of schools sampled 73
percent
are planning remote learning only and
that is a complicated reality because
remote learning
is not an easy solution for everyone
there's a report out right now by common
sense media that estimates up to 16
million public school students
lack either adequate internet access or
computers
and of course you need both if you want
to facilitate remote learning
and by the way the study also found that
it's not just students 10
of teachers fall into this category as
well
now as you might expect this is a matter
of money and so it disproportionately
affects children
in poorer areas for instance look at
scarsdale new york that is one of the
wealthiest school districts in all of
america
98 of households there have a computer
and an internet service connection that
is adequate for remote learning
by contrast one of the poorest districts
san perlita that's in texas
just over half there have a computer and
only 67 percent have an internet
connection adequate
for remote learning in other words guys
one out of three students in that
community
do not have an internet connection that
allows them to learn remotely at least
not well so when we talk about this
national
picture for schools reopening it's
really broken down a lot by not only the
state level
but the district level and then even
beyond that guys
the family level absolutely true i know
my wife experienced this when she was
teaching
earlier in the year through this from
you know at from home to kids at home
every kid had a different circumstance
you know some of them had computers some
not to use their parents computers
some of them were on their parents
iphones every time it was like
individual instructions or anthony you
have the computer and then you don't
have wi-fi
exactly which sort of defeats the
purpose that's why there's so many
layers to this yeah that's why it's so
important to get the kids back but it
has to be done safely in the meantime
remote learning is just not as good as
in classroom learning it just isn't
nope all right let's now let's see how
students in one school district outside
dallas are returning to in-person
learning
wiley east high school has more than
2100 students enrolled
as maria villarreal nearly 60 percent
decided to return for in-person learning
wiley isd is one of the few districts
here in north texas
that decided to start the year with both
in-person
and virtual learning at the same time so
we also got to look inside wiley east
high school from the moment that you
walk
in here you can see that there are signs
everywhere reminding students
and staff to stay at a distance and also
wear their masks because it is a
requirement here in texas
there are also of course hand sanitizing
stations everywhere
here in the cafeteria there are green
dots on the seats to remind students to
sit at a distance and tables are also
staggered every night the bathrooms and
high touch surfaces are sanitized
also teachers were given these emergency
care bags where they have supplies like
masks gloves and also sanitizing liquid
if they need something in an instant
inside their classroom
parents and students say they feel safe
and they realize there's only so much
the district can do
many believe that the benefits of
in-person learning far
outweigh the risk for cbs this morning
mireille villarreal
in wiley texas